[Music]
christian starts off the hour in akron
ohio hi christian how are you
christian
yes sir hey how are you i'm good how are
you sir better than i deserve what's up
uh so i got a kind of a weird situation
me and my wife we're 27 years old we've
been married for two years the only debt
we have left is our mortgage we owe
about 50 000 on it um this the state
just did like an evaluation where they
said it's worth like 200.
i don't love the property for a couple
of reasons but the biggest being
she bought the house before we got
married and her and her ex-boyfriend's
name was on it so when we got married
um i kind of had to go in and change um
you know put my name on the loan and all
that it's just weird living in a house
number one that we don't like and it's
just kind of weird for the both of us
because
uh her ex-boyfriend was living there for
a while so i guess the question that i
have is should we sell our house and
um buy another one like try to sell it
for 200 and then
pay the bank their 50 and then try to
buy within our means
or would you
save up 20
for a down payment on another house or
how would you go about that i guess
well i mean you got 20 because you got
150 000 bucks coming out of there right
well correct as long as it sells
well it's got to sell before you buy
okay that's that would be if i'm gonna
sell it you don't sell you don't buy
unless you sell it
and so you could okay
so you could put it on the market and uh
accept a contract contingent upon your
your ability to locate something that
you like within 30 days
or something like that okay why do you
why do you don't think it's gonna sell
um i don't know i've just heard you know
stories of people who got stuck paying
two
mortgages uh you know that idea kind of
scares me we just got out of um consumer
debt
so the thought of going back to
yeah you're not going to do that you're
not going to get stuck because you're
not going to buy a house unless that one
sells
so the way you would go about this would
be
put it on the market
and then accept the offer except
accept an offer contingent upon
contingent upon or subject to is the
phrasing your ability to find a property
that is suitable to you and your wife
within 30 days
and then you go shopping with the 150
000 that you effectively have in your
pocket
okay but i'm out of there you don't like
the house and it's got ghosts of
boyfriends past and
um
you know i'm out man there's a lot of
reason to check out this deal now here's
the thing you're selling in an up market
and you're going to buy in an up market
so
just be ready for sticker shock right
yeah be sure you can get a house that
you will like that's within your budget
correct would it be smarter to rent and
then kind of wait and see if the market
goes down i don't think the market's
going to go down
it might slow how fast it's going up
but it but i don't think it's going to
go down the number of times the real
estate market the residential real
estate market in
akron ohio has gone down
overall is i'm one time in 50 years
2008.
okay you know it just doesn't go down
much sometimes it's kind of
sluggish and slow and it's not
increasing much but you really don't
lose value in real estate very often
it's very very unusual for a single
family to lose value now you can get in
a bad neighborhood or you can run the
maintenance down and mess up the thing
right but but in general if you maintain
real estate in a decent reasonable
neighborhood in a decent reasonable town
which akron certainly is then you can
you know you can pretty well be assured
it's going to go up it's just lately
it's been going up at white hot
rates it's kind of hockey sticking you
know up and to the right so
that's a problem but but guess what
you're selling in that market and you're
buying in that market so you just give
yourself some latitude and you know if
you go out there for 30 days and you
absolutely can't find anything then you
you have the right to step out of the
deal you've made that deal in your
contract and you've not messed anybody
over
now dave in a hot market like this are
there sellers who go i'm not going to
take that deal where it's contingent
it's not a seller he's the seller yeah
for the for on the buyer's side they
could just be contingent upon
simultaneous closings all and there's
not you know
close them both
the same day and it shouldn't be a big
deal i mean
it might be there might be a buyer who
wants all cash no contingencies
no appraisals no inspections there's
people doing stuff like that but you
just can't buy that house because you
gotta get your zest to close yeah
but you can find you know you can find
people that'll sell a house contingent
upon the
closing of yours that's under contract
that's really not especially the hot
market it's not that big a contingency
it's not that big a problem so
i'd be different if it's contingent upon
the sale and hadn't even put it up for
sale yet that one's a little tougher
but uh in in a hot market like this